okay so uh the title of the stream I
don't know if the YouTube video title
will be the same I don't know if I'll
put this on YouTube
hopefully it goes decently it's called
playing the same opening repertory every
game and this an opening repertory I I
show some students now every student
kind of has our own differences but I'm
gonna stick with what I teach most often
I was planning to play qgd but b3 as an
attempt to maybe create a novelty that
be three looks dubious but how do i
exploit it I'm wondering if this makes
any sense probably not too soon like
usually the problem with b3 it's
weakening at least to the c3 square so
I'm wondering I'm actually calculating
like lines a5 Bishop b4 check on c5
could also make some sense I think I'll
start with c5 and it'll actually be like
a reverse Queens gambit with b3 included
which I don't think should be that
useful for whites maybe it will be okay
on quite completely should be too so I
trying to figure out these lines like a
5 because usually in Queens gambit in
the Ming movie 4
maybe I'm taking this too seriously I
mean he's only 1400 I'm also thinking
about this an e6 and if b4 then there's
a koala known trap let's play e6 I just
want to win back the pond
I'll see if white tries to defend it
it's not too many ways to defend it
before rush of a three Bishop III mm-hmm
hello to people
hello nirvan Raymond Jarrod Baskin as
Bell Iike Belgium novice good to see you
back Shaun's pawn okay so he defends
with Bishop III interesting there's an
idea to take taken Queen e5 check the
problem of things before
oh it's bits double o P double o there's
also 96 ideas 96 is very logical just
attacking the pawn another time
discouraging before but problem with the
bishop on you three it blocks white in
like white can't develop the pawn which
means the bishops a bit more stuck can't
complain you have to always consider
ideas like this because b3 has been
played so early don't worry I'm not in
flagging danger yet I have spent a lot
of time and rafi unnecessarily let's
take with the the Bishop let's stay with
night and now we trade now I'm happy to
have this starts for Bishop and I'm
especially happy that he doesn't have a
dark squared Bishop and because he's
played b3 there's all these dark square
weaknesses this is like a dream come
true for the bishop so he defended it
against my threats I starting Queen here
to double attack I mean I could still
probably play Queen here followed by
Bishop before or Bishop before
immediately mmm
Bishop before Queen d4 it sees two
things
maybe Queen a5 this is a matter of like
finding forcing moves being concretes
Queen a5 looks nice and there's not too
many options and I'm turning ideas of
that it's like Queen 85 I'm not scared
of Bishop b5 check there should be 5
King f8 and then White has issues and
yeah this this mines gonna be
problematic even if I'm not winning
material by the way he wants my queen b5
let's play Bishop should be 4 looks
decent looking at mines Queen b5 take
sticks Bishop g7 takes takes 92 rook c8
King D 2 9 f6 there's a lot of pressure
oh there's also taking on c3 followed by
rookie to see in that line so he plays
this now Queen b5 is no longer possible
I think I'll just play this easy
developing move threatening 94 you just
want to attack the pinned piece one more
time and also drink some tea Hikaru says
hi I say hi to Hikaru
you can't spell Hikaru without hi wait
that doesn't say Hikaru it says here aku
who's here aku a carros evil twin
castling queenside so unpinning the
knights but walking into a volcano
essentially let's play Bishop d7 I'm not
gonna bite immediately but I'm going to
bite eventually and there's so many
ideas here and now I'm also preventing
the Queen trade 100 bits from
Starfighter for the people who are
recommending openings I've actually
already
determined my opening record short for
this tournament and I don't have it in
my stream title but I had it in the
go-live notification go live
notification says playing aggressive
openings or playing aggressive efore
openings as white and then dragon
Sicilian and Queens gambit declined this
black and there's some other openings
which aren't mentioned which I might
have to react to I'm trying to have some
consistency with these games okay so my
pieces are like all developed I still
need to castle and it's a question this
is a question how so like eventually
break through with the attack because
it's not easy to like made on b2 right
away unless it's bughouse then I would
just need to play this and get a queen I
mean I might slow play this on my play
like castling rook c6 rook fc8 I'm just
continually putting straws on the
camel's back I feel like with this setup
I'm reading the chat less because I have
to like physically turn my head on a
different monitor but okay good to see
people are talking Ontario game from
Ontario I'm going to Canada this summer
I'll be in Montreal Switzerland that's a
country I want to go back to I was in
fossil for one day but only one day I
didn't really see much you want to see a
fried liver mmm
fried liver is not in the repertoire
that we'll be playing I'll be playing
dragon is back I'll be
playing actually if we have a two nights
and I'm white I'll be playing a nice
aggressive line nilesy I can chat good
to see you back a shout out to cool guy
shout-out to Chris HGTV wait what's a
syllogism syllogism or syllogism I'm
always nervous about like asking about
words I've never heard before probably
won't ask Siri okay oh it's Castle I
don't think I've three changes too much
I mean maybe why is preparing some pawn
break or some pawn storm but I'm
preparing some rook lifts or some
doubling of rooks and yeah this one move
b3 I think it's going to come back to
bite white because to play b3 so early
and then a handshake Castle queenside
it's not like great condo was out of
three Knights
died miss a free night why did I not
take a free night he plays the night a
floor
I forgot I played receipt with a threat
I just trusted him you never trust your
opponents thankfully I am still in very
good shape I'm winning a pawn I guess in
order to win the night I would have had
to trade off my bishop
maybe it wasn't worth it probably was
worth it I'm just slightly blind getting
distracted by big words in the chat
so now the my files kind of open ish I
can invade with rooks III or bishops III
I mean you should probably calculate
rooks III Queen B 5 mm Bishop c3 Queen B
5 there's also a 5 maybe what I can do
is e5 kick the knight first okay
everything's winning let's play e5 take
the knight if it goes to b3 it looks
like it's defending stuff but it's not
defending b2 and this is a promised land
for my queen b2 is actually a very
difficult score to defend I'm looking
for ways maybe Oh No so you King anyone
rook be one but a ones off-limits and
this idea is just too slow I'm probably
the only way to stop me is to give away
the Queen ah
there's this I forgot now the the knight
can move in the queen will defend
backwards but it's not going to help
because I'll have the real IFFT
so night see one Brooksie six and queen
moves anywhere here play this well but
then Bishop e5 maybe the game can keep
going
yeah it's actually being resourceful I
mean let's do this anyway looks good if
I'm not meeting I'm at the very least
like winning material like one line
Queen B through York v6 Bishop b5 Queen
eighty-five double thread of the bishop
and the Knights and a six possibilities
new location yeah I'm in the cave I'm in
the chest bra apartment and there's no
chest bras anywhere I think they'll
moved to Iceland at least temporarily
scheduled I did add a few more events to
my schedule B sex is fun I'm I will be
playing a few of the shield arenas
coming up
I think the classical shield arena and
the hyperbolic shield arena so very
different types of chess okay good game
I mean that was slightly careless of me
if I saw the knight was hanging I would
have taken it but it all worked out back
to tournaments I'm in the top thousand
nine oh six what openings am i doing so
I'm gonna be doing some aggressive but
sound e for openings and I'll be doing a
dragon Sicilian that's black against e4
and Queens gambit declined this black
against e4 so I'm black again d4 okay so
Lasky my opponent played b3 this game
hopefully we'll have something a bit
more standard we might see a London hey
we see a London just as I saying that
JAMA Iike feeling was saying maybe a few
London's as well so let's take down the
London c5 this is my recommendation
usually with knight c6 and queen bee
six to follow white might be playing the
right move order here there's yeah
there's nine f3 which is slightly
dubious ninety two's about a better move
and now the problem with going for Queen
b6 is that after Queen B 3 C 4 Queen C 2
I would like to play Bishop f5 but he
could just take it because after Queen
takes me to the rooks not trapped so I'm
gonna go default to a different line
that is also a bit tricky starts with e
6 and then it's a line that Wesley so
pioneered it looks passive at first like
I'd lock in my bishop trading on d4
usually white doesn't mind the idea is
after I takes d4 I can play Knight h5 so
I'm breaking a few principles moving the
same piece twice moving away from the
center blocking in my own Bishop but the
whole idea I want to get the bishop pair
and if white tries to keep the bishop on
the board then there is interesting
types of counter play
for example if Bishop here I play
something like this and then eventually
neither 4 if Bishop here never mind a
bishop here I would have the same plan
of accessing out for I think I can do
this yeah the natural move Bishop to e3
just friends into Knight f4 then the
best move is probably to go back to at
Florin and f6 is actually useful even
though maybe it seems weakening at first
I want to prepare ePHI and just have a
good Center and like everything it kind
of has this purpose for black given this
Bishop will find a home someday
wait what I evolved from natal I saw him
at all tall in Latvia at least saw a
statue of him have to find the picture
but first things first hmm Queen c2
signifying that light and light Castle
queenside and then go for some King side
attack also if I Castle and he plays
Bishop t3 there's immediate threats so
I'm thinking I could delay it could play
nine afore immediately I could play g5
maybe like I'm not too scared I'm just
trying to sort out the options my e5
also may be possible in the near future
I'm actually wondering like castling
Bishop d3 wondering about this move g6
this takes g6 doesn't work I've met g7
otherwise the outlets Castle because I
want to I want to get ready to play e5
have ideas of like maybe Queen b6 or
Queenie eights whoa Nile Homer gifting
10 subs thanks Nile Homer I don't know
there's sound for the subscriber thing
but I appreciate the gifts I'll read off
the names if I get a chance I'm playing
g6 going along with the plan
welcome everyone so the new sub Club
some stuff I just missed in the chat I
still want to bring up the picture of me
and tall but yeah new subs Zophar Benjy
Bob guru wait as a sub notification
working
I'm sure it is but maybe it's not editor
box Oh the alert box is under there we
go okay that was being hidden
sorry about that so while my opponent
thinks who else do we have Giroux 88 a
name with no consonants or no vowels I
can't pronounce it but I can spell it KN
w NW spectacular camel bad a bap si si
que si howls Helsinki Freund victual
squid and Schwalb Schwalb in chess
welcome everyone and thanks again to
nyle Homer okay so castling queenside
this is gonna be a sharp game but it
should be hopefully straightforward to
play for a win I do want to attack I
could consider playing this immediately
why not attack defend attack not sure if
I ever want to take on g2 because Rick
g1 but I like an island f4 I still want
to complete development like Bishop d7
rook c8 ideas of night before so Bishop
f1 actually thinking about this if takes
Bishop a5 Intermezzo hmm not sure if
white ever wants to play g3 my knight
might be stable here takes
there's about five queen bee three ticks
ticks ticks I mean this just looks great
t3 could be weak going for it if white
doesn't take I have ideas of efore so
light takes so Bishop f5 Oh Bishop f5
there's Queen a for attacking this night
and I can't take back with pawn I was a
slight oversight so let's uh let's yeah
let's take first if he doesn't take and
allows Bishop f5 and life is so good I
have so much dominance over the square
I'm expecting take stakes and I still
have ideas of Bishop f5 and I'll have to
beastly bishops combined with the C file
and the King won't be able to escape
because I'll control b1 like even now
King b1 just runs into Bishop f5 Joe
grew and get to see you back
94 so trying to prevent this now the bad
move I don't think thinking just Bishop
here at the knight b3 mmm here's Queen
a5 10 king b1 should speed up the tempo
too
Queen a5 king b1 I should see 593 takes
Knight takes rook c8 I'm not seeing
anything clear I should G for ideas I'm
looking at like all the forcing moves so
what does white want to do here can I
just leave the tension somehow and
improve like Bishop d7 g5 the night is
so annoying
controlling f5 it's on one square I want
access to so Bishop g4 f3 does that help
me in any way
probably just helps whites there's also
some idea here Bishop g3 then Bishop g4
you should g4 and then maneuver takes a
long time though
okay I just have to decide on a move
between b6 r b5 hmm v king b1 okay I
have an idea I'm gonna start with king
or queen b5 because it like it prevents
flight from doing anything immediate has
to defend this pawn expecting team b1
now I'll play this just simple not
really changing too much I'm trying to
actually provoke night b3 if it looks
very natural and then after I'll play
Queen b6 and get ready to push the a
pawn
White's going for something different
let's move the knight back I'll be
speeding things up be very happy as
Bishop takes and I take then have Bishop
f5 later also have ideas of like rook
either up to c8 okay never mind I was
thinking pawn swarming with the b-pawn
but now I'll pawn storm with a pawn
and good to see more people pawn star
23:06 royal it's from sinister hologram
thanks for the bits and thanks for the
comments even if you're insulting my
jokes f4 let's play I kind do this or
this let's do this I'm threatening 93
now I have the bishop pair white doesn't
have a light squared Bishop and I do and
this is a dream 92 expected to probably
play rook c8 I mean this would be fancy
here and then here but the 94 okay I'll
play route see it's f4 is kind of
hanging
well it's chess in the chat
what's up chess such an OG name uh can I
take no I can't take and there's so much
pressure when like the chess itself is
watching what do I do
Bishop here all that that hangs upon
Bishop g4 I could just take the other
Bishop feel like there's something good
somewhere let's just put a rock on an
open file rooks on open files have
smiles I can take this whenever I want
to
lessee moves it but then maybe I can
take this this square if I get any minor
piece to the square that would be so
nice like the knight or the bishop this
is another case if this heard bughouse
like it's just so amazing I mean you
can't spell Lee chest without chess
right
I'll be going to to San Francisco soon
for the PCL finals really looking
forward to the event whoa f5 okay time
is running low with Niner Bishop take
away the bishop keeps the initiative
taken with Knights is more positional
let's take with Bishop keeping
initiative in the end I'll be hitting
the rook end f5 but f5 is defended three
times rook F 3 might come yeah this is
going to be a fight I could take we
trade some stuff wait a minute no if
white wants to take a bunch of times yes
to sack the exchange so takes takes
takes takes takes there's some comp but
probably not enough comp for whites I'll
play Queen e6 there won't even be any
checks I'll hold on to my pawns life
will be good King h8 I'll be safe
how many people will be in San Francisco
for the pcl finals pretty sure Eric
Hanson will be there
I think Fabiana will be there all these
people okay so this is what I was
calculating and then I'm feeling pretty
safe
you
like even though there's not the best
shelter it's not too many attackers and
maybe I can start attacking past pond 99
with a sub good to see you back yeah a
long time that was see I'm not playing
in Iceland
that's a treatment that's on my bucket
list but it takes planning and honestly
I I would want to go to Iceland just for
travel and not necessarily to play like
a 9 round tournaments so I might try to
go there at some points
cuz I've been there I mean I've thumbed
through like at the airports I did like
a two-day trip there but it wasn't that
long I was too short to really see
everything ok I should not flag let's
play well let's not hang out 6 what do I
do here where is a quickest win
Queeny 5 let's start with King h8 I mean
46 seconds is still a decent amount of
time another sub InfoSec thanks for
subbing the subs get access to the dome
flag emotes which I usually need
constant reminders for
okay rook h8 not too scared let's play
rook here I just want to play Queen I
five trade Queens keep life simple
the police don't flag thanks for
reminding but you're also kind of
distracting me because now I'm just
looking at the chat forgetting about the
board okay it's Czech defending and now
maybe I went a night Kings see one
expected King see one rook dat rookie to
clear up d8 I was looking at rookie -
and then Queen h6 is kind of weird
and then at three maybe expected let's
just do this I mean everything's
defended I think it's from someone
Brogan five hundred bits distraction
bits but I'm not getting distracted too
much I don't think I'm keeping my pawns
defended I have to try harder if you
want to distract me I want to play b4
just keep storming there we go a5 keep
storming 33 Queen h6
have to give my credit though and
playing some decent resistance I want to
play queen g6 next and rook b8 and cream
of that I think White's going going to
flag despite being up time so much of a
game okay maybe not the best technique
and not the best time management for
sure but it was an interesting position
maybe I play d5 too soon I should
probably probably should have prepared
it I'm actually looking now at Queen e5
King b1 and 95 then this is a monster
threat well it's more bits from Brogan
500 good game bits yeah good game bits
are usually better than distraction bits
we look at the board
what does stockfish say queen eight five
big plus for black Oh Queen 85 oh yeah
Queen 85 is up there Bishop d7 sawfish
is so patience sometimes but we need
five what does white do yeah G 3 would
be ugly okay yeah it was pleasant yeah
this is a more high level line I think
most amateurs aren't aware of this move
order but it's good to be prepared as
black and it's still offbeat enough
where you can get white out of their
comfort zone so let's go back to
tournaments we have another sub whoa we
don't have another sub that's a that's a
badge broken just earned the new five
kbits badge
congratulations Brogan I didn't know
that was a thing well well I played
daily hyper I have it in my schedule to
play the hyper shield arena
I feel fast like this mouse this is Eric
Hanson moss
it has such a good fuel let's keep this
instructive and not the zerk I'm black
again this is my third black in a row
what's going on is my opponent here
maybe opening up my stream shoutout to
my opponent ah too slow
hey I gained high rating points back to
tournament oh yeah I was gonna bring up
a picture of me and tall flickr.com was
it their president photography me find
this picture this was a while ago people
were mentioning tall hey I'm white in a
game let's play you four okay get ready
for a picture of tall whoa a thousand
bits finally call the stream these are
distraction bits it's hard to distract
me at the beginning of the game come to
Sweden and play sometime I went to
Sweden I was in Sweden for like an hour
I took a ferry from Denmark got off the
ferry had to go through passport control
it was was the only time I've gone
through passport control that wasn't
like off a plane what is this line D six
a few years ago I was in Australia and I
was playing someone you played this line
I was preparing like pretty heavily for
it cuz d6 it's it's a playable moon I'm
sure my opponents just playing it like
just trying to follow basic opening
principles but there's an interesting
way to meet it usually after Bishop b6 I
can play Bishop to b5 and some may be a
bit strange looking but this pin can be
annoying I'm trying to remember what to
do after this
maybe just castling or do I plead
that's 35 I'm probably just castling
trying to remember why the bishop wants
to be on b5 oh yeah I wants to be on b5
- not allowed Bishop g4 well you have
why the last Bishop g4 or like there's a
lot of pressure against d4 um so now I
can develop hopefully pretty comfortably
I might even play h3 causevox now this
black training Bishop g4 probably not
yet because I would have d5 so I'll
develop and then after castling then box
threatening Bishop g4 and then I'll play
h3 and this is one of the reasons why
you should like when you learn openings
you should understand the ideas rather
than just memorizing moves because I
studied this like a couple years ago but
I remember this specific idea like don't
allow to shove g4 all right now it's
just Pleasant that's a dream opening
setup people are saying stuff in the
chat you end up down a few points by
points do you mean material do you mean
computer evaluation oh yeah in computer
analysis against qgd I mean Queens got
declined
you shouldn't be like losing out of the
opening that has a solid reputation
sometimes computer will spit out like
plus 0.5 right plus 0.8 and it's still a
very like solid playable position so the
main thing I would say is don't trust a
computer too much in terms of like if
it's only giving like a fraction of a
point if it's giving like +2 then
something has gone wrong
I play Bishop here Bishop c4 probably
Bishop here having access to these
squares you enjoyed the cameo a cameo of
the other night with Eric and Fadi yeah
the other nights this wasn't on my
stream it was on the chest broth stream
was Eric Hansen Fabiano Benjamin Bach I
was a second lowest rated player in the
apartment
because there is Lawrence but it was a
good group good time yeah I'm pretty
sure there's a delay with the stream
it's usually like 5 or 10 seconds
oh I'm not g6
first move that comes to mind is Bishop
g5 if I can provoke f6 I'm happy let's
do it
if f6 I can play I should be three check
and move back
I'm trying to calculate there should be
three kiemce here we moved back block
does have f5 hmm but now I have like 95
ideas let's do it the great thing about
this position I have the space advantage
and all of the minor pieces are
unimportant which just favours me well
it's a donation
Jonathan Sampson saying loving your
videos on YouTube and tipping there with
dat from brave what does that mean I'm
not sure what tipping there with b80
from brave means or back from brave it's
bad a type of currency okay this is an
interesting move Bishop c2 night c4
bishop c1 I just don't want to trade off
minor pieces if it's not necessary
and if Knight C for bishops he won the
Knights kind of awkward b3 ideas
question do you use your phone to click
the primary mouse bone hahaha yes this
is like when I did the st. Louis Chess
Club YouTube videos when I was first
starting out this is one of the biggest
criticisms because this is how I hold
the mouse people can see my thumb is on
the button I don't know it's been a
habit I've just gotten used to it I know
it looks kind of weird but I mean deal
with it
be three trap the nights be 395 maybe I
just play slow and let's start with b3
easy move I think maybe one reason why I
use it weirdly is because I'm like I
write lefty I was trained to use a mouse
writing and I still do different things
like depending on the thing I do
something's left you something's righty
so it's slightly confusing some things I
can do like with both hands like
ping-pong ping-pong chopsticks okay 95 I
want to play d5 prevent 96 d5 opens up
some stuff
you know it's a great position just a
question how to how to make things even
better I mean I'm not sure what Locke's
gonna do next
I might just play rookie one like very
simple improving move sometimes this is
not a bad strategy
so taking so much time just play simple
improving moose wait for the opponent to
either give you some opportunity give
you some targets or just self-destruct
ob8e is a utility token in the brave
browser I use it to support streamers
and content creators you can verify your
account to receive the VA though
interesting so I have to get the brave
browser I think I've heard about this
actually like during there's a point in
time as more into cryptocurrency okay
I'll look into it I do appreciate it
Bishop a7 so maybe preparing b5 I want
to play h4 h5 but that allows Bishop g4
play Bishop e3 wants some plan
could maneuver the mind don't see
anything wrong with this 93 I want to be
in shape to attack have access to all
these squares
maybe someday this and this and either
this or this like if both knights and
both bishops can start at least having
some potential it'll be more fun for
everyone except my opponent is this my
main opening your couture I have
different types of repertories this is
more of a student repertoire the reason
why I like to play and study so many
openings is because different students
play different types of openings and
it's it's fun to like learn the ins and
outs and the nuances and certain
openings are suited better for certain
levels of players answering styles of
players which is why like sometimes I
let my students choose their openings or
I like if they need help I'll recommend
them what to play
still looking for plans c5 can be coming
next idea of a c5 as black wants to get
rid of this pawn get the e5 square I
could take
looking at just some simple idea ignite
f5 like 905 attacking this I'd be
attacking the rookie on f7 here it takes
takes attack the mites and get the
bishop here I've already had the bishop
here and two games so far yeah we'll
play this makes things a bit complicated
there's a lot of things that could be
trade either and taken very soon would
you ever do a course for chesa below
possibly yeah if I did a course for
testable it would be on I mean it would
be some opening repertories obviously I
just have so many things on my plates
but in the not too distant future but
kind of between the near future and
distant future would be when I I
considered doing a chestful course h4 h5
ideas now I should move quicker just
want to get the bishop to f4
in d5 also very logical so many options
let's play this clear plan if the light
moves away I guess you could take takes
H 595 mm my take I mean there's so much
that can happen like you could take your
first take your first try you Brooks if
you wants I mean it Bishop takes why the
way I think I'm happy we trade
everything this night is hit in the end
that's 97 I mean I'll be happy if I have
the bishop here at the end of this it's
been a while since I played benoni
all occasionally get like benoni
structures but having are playing a
mainline Benoni almost never
now there's a mod JK son of itch
thanks for subbing and infinite flash
chess rating with a party of five thanks
so much
so they take your first yeah let's take
have the Knights support each other I
actually could be losing upon Mike and
Bishop takes I have to take the knight
and then there's my takes H for I think
I'd be happy to lose H pawn though get
the Queen to h5 like Queen h5 Knight g6e
5 opening up the bishop
the more arrows you draw the faster the
checkmate you'll find not sure if arrows
are the the number of arrows correlate
with speed of check meeting being
interesting data science problem Raph
Rika welcome back
yeah the person using the London emotes
I guess I did have a London last game
but the only time I'll have a London for
this stream is playing against the
London I need travel plans for near
future
yes I'll be going to California
possibly LA and definitely San Francisco
this is a serious move attacking the
rook pressuring this guy and late Bishop
III or Bishop d2 even skewering I was
about to play Bishop III but this looks
better
the Queen has to move Queen c7 does
defend their lives but then I can carry
through with h5 or Queen h5 or even like
Queen c7 takes takes and then takes here
looks good
rook c1 I have a feeling White's gonna
lose on time or not are not white the
blacks gonna lose on time I was thinking
of last game where I my opponent lost on
time
Oh Oh ray was asking what my favorite
openings were and you use a London you
know okay gotcha
make sense yeah I'll save like a London
repertory probably for another extreme
whoa free queen kind of whites winning
material for it though like white one
the minor piece two minor pieces and now
the exchange but I have countered play
if rookie seven a queen here hitting
this in threatening 907 that's nice
having an extra Queen am I going to
California for chess related work yeah
I'll be in San Francisco for the
protesting finals
last year I was there I was doing work
for us chess taking photos took a lot of
photos last year and actually if you
look on like chess comm they're using a
lot of my photos to promote the events
which is pretty cool
whoa I hear this work like you're a king
here by age 16 eh-eh there's no
smothered mate hmm confusing I mean I
couldn't do anything and flag of it I
want to play something something nice
I have seven like what's the best move
here so I don't think 9 f 7 actually
works lease is so effective if you just
queen h5 b queen c5 there's lots of
different targets I'll probably take a
rook I'm training before and threatening
to flag him
can you threaten to flag your opponents
ok good game yeah that was those reason
we solid is some offbeat opening yeah
this Bishop e5 move is nice
cuz if white doesn't play Bishop e5 I
think it's it's not bad for luck like
castling and Bishop g4 and it's kind of
annoying
why didn't I Knight f7 not work if I
play 907 in the end ok computer says
everything's winning 9 f7 here runs into
King jeans and then at any Knight
discovery with exception of that h6 will
lose a queen so I have to like double
check then after this Queen g8 fails to
row takes g8 I don't have 907 means
meanwhile the Queen and the knight would
be attacked so wait did it work
people are saying that worked let's
check stock fish stock fish knows best
I mean White's still winning hi Queen c5
here still but in this position yeah I
mean it's still playable if I go for
this Queen c5 move eventually the a
Queen c5 immediately is just better
because my Knights more centralized
Andrew chess welcome back okay so I
already referenced like a few photos I
guess I can show photos here I move this
oh there's a photo of me and tall this
was taken in Latvia in Lafayette people
have like asses at their end of their
names I don't know if it's like a
misspelling or a custom yeah so that's a
photo I have a Flickr page with a bunch
of photos maybe I'll link the protest
the photos are somewhere on the Flickr
page anyway let's play another game I'm
in three hundredths place I'm on a
streak I'm not going to be fighting for
first maybe I'll be fighting for top
hundred or something
when did tall yeah when did tall pass
away not sure sure Wikipedia knows oh
there's a tall emote Oh from narrowed
its key nice alright so sticking with
the same repertory Queens gambit
declined whoa we have a black more
Deemer when in doubt accept the gambit
and win a pawn I'm actually not in doubt
though like this is still kind of
classic stuff usually white plays off
three now I'm gonna play a move which is
part of my repertoire part of my
preparation it's a very strange-looking
move at first pawn c6 the idea is that
after or if light were to take I could
play e5 with a nice position Bishop f4
I've never seen before
I know I'm on my own
I mean Bishop f5 looks very intuitive I
don't want to take I don't want to make
white happy and accelerate his
developments Queen 85s also move it's
one of the possibilities with playing c6
early I'm gonna play Bishop f5 just
defending Bishop g6 could be very solid
why didn't I desert I'm not really
looking to like fight first top spot in
the tournament and I'm trying to be
instructive with these games there will
be other times were all berserk a lot
more frequently but g4 g4 is interesting
because if I move back g5 9595 I hit the
bishop so I don't think white is
actually winning a pawn we're winning
the pong back does she route have a
statue so I mean sure I was still alive
and doing pretty well actually in the
same Flickr album I also have a picture
with Shira like real life shear off he's
not dead yet
that's so opt-ins no sure I was like I
mean I play them in Latvia and he's he's
still an active player 9595 as a
candidate moves the question is is white
threatening anything because now the
bishops defended white might want to
take so I could could consider taking up
three checks f3 Queen jigs f3 Queen
takes d4 and rook d1 and then it's a
little bit scary but I'd be up to pawns
there's some interesting calculation
takes left 3 takes f3 Queen takes d4
rook to e1 Bishop e4 there should be 4
Queen e2 mmm let's stay got three first
not sure if I'll take t4 I might just go
and be solid but I'll let white think
yeah I don't want to like give him the D
file I don't want to put so much energy
into a position where I can just develop
normally 97 probably and okay there's
some attacking potential it's gonna be a
shark game you should be five
interesting considering a bishop before
I should be four g5 and there's Bishop
h5 yeah let's play Bishop before
well I create some ideas I'm gonna find
the picture there's a picture I've
sheared off via could take and pawn
takes maybe h6
h6 there's 94 so I could take I mean I
could start trading a lot of stuff and
then 94 then h6 preventing 94 feels
wrong giving away my bishop takes takes
h6
let's go for this oh we have another son
thanks for the sub Feld tub 85 I need to
find a way to turn on a sound
pawn takes I was not expecting he stole
this actually this is stronger now
because he still doesn't have access to
e4 and at night h3 Bishop b4 and I might
just be winning a full rook or a queen
okay let's find sheriff this picture
this picture
people can't see it now people can kind
of see it it's blurry the game he beat
me like I was lost after 11 or 12 moves
and it's on YouTube too if you just type
in like my name and cheer off into
youtube as it's a painful memory was
this smooth Queen h3 Queen h3 pinning
the pawn to the rook what a miracle
scene I'm considering keen e7 defending
my rook or just castling mm feel like
this shouldn't work but maybe I just
played Queen 85 like I have multiple
attacks on multiple different flanks
oh the same treatment I played sure of I
also played sveshnikov who's also still
alive it's fashion icon you also just
beat me and this games on YouTube too
from some YouTube channel rapid chess oh
let me switch back to this ok so I could
take the bishop and win upon pick
queenside castle there's another one in
you spots like a lot of things are
winning I just want to be solid yeah
let's take the bishop you have two pawns
I'll have initiative I might be winning
more stuff like meta 3 queenie for
attacking this animus
also ideas of 95 and like be 5.4 if
you're a bishop here I take I mean we
trade stuff I mean the better approach
might be to keep Queens on the board
Queen f4 may be like why not for just
applying pressure
ideas of this didthis both both
especially cosplay are playing regularly
or wait oh they're playing in Paris are
they usually playing Paris I've never
actually been to Paris I wasn't aware
that there is some regular tournament
there but I'm not surprised yeah I would
like to go to Paris at some point it's
not like so high on my bucket list but
it would be cool
roti for I kind of forgot about like
Queen III III I mean it feels like my
Queen should be a target but it can't
easily be attacked I'm controlling these
squares with my bishop and I want to
play Knight e5 to attack the pond also
pinning the night and I'm still up two
pawns so life is pretty good
you guys want music I have to figure out
how to add music cuz I don't want to add
something that's like copyrighted and
then have the thing be muted for the
replay this looks like a beautiful move
because how does white defend also I'm
finding this maybe there's some weird
knight move like Knight H for defense
III via x-ray vision but then I can take
just play some angle do I dare put on
chess brought techno music squeal saying
no music in all caps
yeah I'm not gonna take compacting to
take some of these recommendations jazz
would probably be more suitable or like
some I don't know what I like to listen
to I type in intense focus into Spotify
and Hall has like all these playlists
like focus instrumental music so nice
but yeah I'll look into it or maybe
someone can look into it for me message
later there's a playable playlist coward
pong with a hundred bits yes all
playlists are playable by definition but
something that's playable and that's
like fair use or copyright free so I'm
up material I have a good position but
I'm down on time this could take a while
longer does music help me play not
really just another distraction not h4
maybe he's listening in yeah it's
probably one of the best moves lets
anything else I could take I mean I kind
of wanted to keep Queens on the board
it's time to trade
should save the bishop it's never too
late to castle know when there's only
one open file maybe use it to trade some
stuff always play off six f6 is nice in
this case kicks away the Knights
undermines the rook prepare d5 now this
move looks nice tacking kind of
attacking both rooks also hitting c2
which work do I want to take probably
this rook I see four ideas I take C two
ideas even ninety one I knew this 91
I mean White's like almost completely
stuck like this could be very close to
zoos long like the Knights dominated the
bishops dominated the rooks tied down I
played King hearing because I'm dreaming
of this this this and then somehow
meeting the pawns might need to come
into play let's play rook d2 simple
threat of this just trapping the bishop
if Knight f3 rook F to
also maybe just winning Mac I do I have
made special g8 not quite let's start
with bishops you just want to see where
the King moves if King be - I'll take
now the bishops trapped
oh you just sent me a playlist nice
but I'm not sure like I'll probably save
it for next stream because I'm not sure
about like the audio levels it would
require some testing this is tricky I
move away to fend the nights now this
night has to go somewhere awkward
I mean ih4 move back here restricting
the nights targeting c2 let's take a lot
of material no counterplay let's try and
meet the quickest way possible that
works
beebee weights very close to meeting the
king in the center let's start with this
and then this creating something like c5
let's do this
I'm really trying to meet the King in
the center so I have to be careful not
to steal me there we go okay work son
and Gigi yeah some dubious gambits just
to show some preparation and explain c6
is that after it takes e5 is nice
it takes takes whatever it takes back I
mean if Knight takes I take the pawn if
King takes I still win back the pawn and
it's a nice line against gambit player
because it diffuses everything needs to
some better positional game for black
there's one other line which sometimes
comes from a different move order if I
plays Bishop g5 here there's 97 then it
takes there's still a file and after it
takes the main reason for playing c6 is
to have this move Queen a5 very
beautiful and maybe this has occurred in
like master play and blacks worse really
well because black just wants to take
back if the bishop trades for Knights
then black starts for Bishop is very
happy so let's go back to tournaments
wait is it done
oh there's a tournament okay waiting for
a game a blonde cloud glory awaits yeah
I'm done playing the belong tag for a
while house maybe a once in a blue moon
thing or can we say once in a black hole
thing it's black hole craze okay yeah
I'm not aspiring to be a BM I'm black
again I think I've only been white one
game we have a this is the first time
playing against you for this stream so
I'm planning to play the dragon dragon
is probably one of the simplest like
Sicilians to play black has very
harmonious developments and then usually
pretty clear attacking plans in in the
middle game Bishop c4 Bishop c4 so soon
as this maybe it's playable dragons not
like my main opening weapon and I've
mainly learned it through teaching it to
students so I'll admit I'm not familiar
with this line
I think I'll just like Kari through
normally castle get ready to play this
probably have to look this up afterwards
yeah similar to my aspirations of
becoming a BM I don't really have too
many aspirations at least to get the GM
title like so soon because I have other
priorities and even when you're an IM it
takes a lot of time and effort and
travelling to tournaments to get the GM
title and these days I'm more focused on
teaching and doing online contents but
I'm still playing a little bit I have a
few tournaments coming up but nothing
too intensive 96 okay so we have a
position well it looks like light might
be going for like this Yugoslavia TAC
I'm wondering if you somehow tricked me
into an accelerator dragon where I
commit to d6 early but maybe that just
means it's a normal dragon I have a
feeling here there's moves like Queen a5
there is a scheme from the US Women's
Championship was it taught to Avraham UN
against arena crush and there is some
early like a 5 or Queen a 5 Queen b6
could also be playable between us Queen
b6 serves Knight f5
I'm just gonna play Bishop d7 I mean
this is usually the normal like
development scheme followed by Roxy AIDS
I applied plays Queen detuned castles
I'll be back in my prep another sub from
furbot FPS thanks for subbing do you
appreciate it very common plan and I
don't know if it's a plan I'll go for it
but it's always something to consider is
rook c8 then either Knight move and then
invading the square c4
now if like Queens like castles 95 is a
mainline um but I have a different line
in mind that I would play which is which
is maybe a bit less theoretical but
still dangerous and also really
interesting but we'll see what happens
if white doesn't castle what else is
white 2h 4 is a move okay so this is a
position yet 95 I'm sure there's been
thousands of games I'm gonna take on d4
and this is actually one of the things
okay we reached it from a different move
order but this is one of the first lines
I show students in the dragon because
it's a very very simple plan and
everything kind of makes sense after
Bishop takes d4 d5 and I just apply a5
a4 now I am kind of stacking a pawn if
he takes it it gets kind of interesting
he doesn't take it okay this is coming
and the reason for taking on d4 is to
like have control over b5 Bishop
supports b5 and now we'll see what
happens
Bishop takes a 7 now I have to remember
I play this first I showed this to a
student just a couple of days ago
actually and there's actually a really
cool line that if we don't get into I'll
have to show afterwards it's just it's
one of these things that you don't see
every day
so before I think the Knights want to
have my rook have a little bit more
sighting against White's King the main
move is this s-92 might also be playable
though it is a bit passive
and very soon I would like to exploit
this Bishop like I have multiple moves
to gain a temple on the bishop and maybe
a tackle on a file how many pull-ups can
I do at least five but like
consecutively I'm not sure you know
pull-up bar okay this is um yeah this is
not the main line so now I kind of have
to think I mean this still looks
attractive
there's also Queen c7 but the idea of a
queen a5 hitting the bishop and then
Bishop a4 actually looks really nice
because if this bishop goes away then
it's easier to attack stuff
so hitting the bishop bishop pretty much
has to move this is I mean these two
moves are probably most likely and it's
important to remember and this is
something that if you play the dragon
for a while
you got accustomed to is that sometimes
there's sneak attacks with Bishop h6
doesn't make any sense at least too soon
but it's always a move so I'm keeping
your back pocket I mean the clear plan
is Bishop a4 maybe even like 97 to c5 so
Bishop a4
I mean Bishop a4 there's a serious
threat of taking takes and then I made
on a1 so there should a for if white
takes takes king by9
rook a8 and there's Knight c16 takes
king b1 it still looks fun
I would like to be winning somehow
Bishop a4 takes takes king b1 c2 also
tender
maybe Bishop h6 there takes takes hmm
let's just start with us it's a position
that I think is rich enough with ideas
even if I'm not winning should have a
nice game another sub I see defeat
thanks for subbing
no it's so nice a files open and like
what White was the one who opened a file
for me I'm taking on a seven so I'm
gonna try and keep calculating hearing
because I'm not entirely sure what I
play after this line I mean this is
standard on maybe just improving I could
get the bishop here to the take on c1
problem is controlling the square
another time maybe H 15 each seven
Bishop h6 ideas
Queens III not what I is expecting the
first thing that comes to mind is Bishop
h6 check forcing move followed by Bishop
b5 and then the Queen is the queen is
actually trapped
I get Bishop h6 King be one Bishop b5
the Queen has no squarings sometime the
question is I can like play f4 and still
this maybe I'm just winning upon I would
like to win more than upon f4 bishop
their queen up three takes takes takes
it looks nice feels so close to just
being winning just trying to find like
the knockout punch it should be five
queen e3 there's also Queen g5 probably
not the best Bishop h6 f4 r z5 Bishop e3
and Bishop e5 Queen d2 takes takes takes
52 hmm prom is a bishop staying on b3
Bishop h6 f4 there should be five Queen
f3
the pawns are so fragile I like when I
could win a floor I mean also just like
simple preparation I might have to be
patient
what does what I want to do probably
taking Queen b3 I mean these lines look
so fun I might be missing something I'm
in flavor c7 honestly Brooke c7 was a
move I didn't consider until like the
last maybe 15 to 20 seconds of of my
whole like thinking on that move but it
doesn't change too much it just aims to
add another Brooke into play I still
have all my resources I'll check back
afterwards like I didn't see anything
maybe sock wish would see something
King me one reasonable of the look like
to bring the night to see five
looks very reasonable question is do I
include this move first
rook D to do I take first or Bishop I
mean I still have to ship each six maybe
not as strong speech six takes on f6
gets weird
yeah ninety-seven I mean this is just a
natural plan I'm allowing the trailor
bishops but then all my pieces will be
ready to hopefully have some attack on
the Queen side I was honestly thinking
this is going to be like an easier game
but White's
putting up some defense and now going
for some attack nice e5 takes or Bishop
e5 risks
let's play 95 first I'm not sure if I
want to take on b3 with them either with
the bishop or just leave all the tension
but there is idea just like maybe taking
with the vision and rogue a sudden the
night Siwon wouldn't be over so checks i
play e5 Windex e6 does that work takes
takes e5 Queen takes c6 takes
defending and then if it takes rook d7
winning the rook I think that works
there's this move though but then I take
I think this is okay you can call my
bluff if you wants take the pawn the
important thing after takes takes takes
after rook d7 my bishop defends the rook
there's no time to take the bishop and I
would be run at winning the rook and the
Queen defends the pawn also very
important after takes takes there's no
intermediate Queen takes e5 so I'm
expecting Queen here but then I'll take
and whatever pawn digs back I think I
just play this initiative I think I can
still do this okay a takes losses on the
spot to this so C takes
just trying to think ahead like Knight
c1 how to make progress
probably 96 yeah things are working
together I mean these moves don't really
help save the king then I just take yeah
this is a beautiful square for the
knight just so many nice stark squares
combined with the pawns I might have the
idea of taking down two pawns now maybe
94 first and you could take have this
move first let's play 94 first it could
be that after rook takes d4 White will
end up having can I count
yeah White has three pawns for the
exchange but I still have some attack we
check now switch over to the C file
[Music]
yeah weights gonna flag or like it mated
this looks very fun just for zines one
good game okay I was not looking at the
chat for probably the last three or four
minutes
how many chess pieces can i balance on
my face such insightful questions there
are a lot of things to talk about in
that game I guess there's two moments I
want to look at one for myself and one
just for the audience yeah I'm gonna
skip over like the opening move order I
first want to look at the point after
[Music]
after Queen d3 I really thought there
should be something here there's so many
different resources but I didn't see
anything that could work which is why I
played rook c7 I I'm just gonna cheat so
I'll get a quick answer from stockfish
oh so this saying Bishop h6 check is the
only way to like win so Bishop h6 f4
Bishop Bishop takes b3 people see this
people can see it Bishop takes b3 I
forgot I could win me four pawn like
this I don't think let's cross my mind's
I guess this is like nice for black
there's ideas of this these files are
open I won back the pawns there's
different x-rays against the King okay
so that was the first moment the other
moment came earlier
I'm not accepting challenges right now
sorry guys
privacy never all changes sometime in
the future though after yeah after
before I want to show this to people in
the chat also another sub Thank You Zhu
Bert scoobert and thanks for the
comments been waiting for my prime sub
nice so in this position there's a
really cool line let's turn off engine
and I'll leave this as kind of a test
for the chats there's one key move I
have I'll try and have you guys find
after 95 there's this main line after
takes takes and then what is it to
remember the Queen 85 am Bishop d4 and
this is actually the position which
inspired me to play this line it's like
the next move in this position it's just
so beautiful that okay I didn't really
don't really have that dragon as my main
weapon but it's kind of a nice side line
it's employed me to teach this to
students black to move in this position
I'll let the chat think I'm gonna make
some more tea so back to move feel free
to take your time and I'll be back
what are people saying whoa
okay rook takes youtuber takes you to
Queen takes a to rook see for rooks III
move out with up time Queen a1 nades
I'd be nice if it was legal
Brooks III Rex III the ice with some
explanation bishop df3
you should d f 3e v Bishop h6 ePHI
Brooks you two okay Bishop a4 okay some
of you are right you curious if anyone's
seen this before the move here is rook
takes c2
it's incredible like this doesn't happen
every day three different pieces can
take the rook but whatever white takes
back with it's fine for black I think
the worst way I can take back was is
with the king
because then after was it rook c8 or no
Oh Bishop f5 first preventing King be
one king c1 Roxy it this is like already
winning for black if Bishop c2 you can
take on a two and this is the threats
it's beautiful like whites up a full
rook but it doesn't matter
so king c2 fails if Queen takes c2 then
simply rook c8 and I think this leads to
a position which is approximately equal
but it should still be pleasant for
black will draw a master's database
yeah we can use Sokka SH - oops I'll
race ya Y has to be precise like cake
stakes and then like king b1 is
necessary otherwise I think there's fish
about five ideas what does this Bishop
takes Queen C five king b1 yeah
likes usually the two rooks are okay
against the Queen here with the
inclusion of this Bishop and this being
a bad digit ideas of this it's just more
pleasant for a black Bishop C to hear
Queen F - yeah White has all these
potential weaknesses and the pawns and
then one more line after what kicks C -
oops did I just do take C - in this
position if if Bishop takes C - then
there's his nice move Queen takes a -
and it's somewhat of a mess but if
you're playing this is black and you
just know like these resources and
you're you're good enough at like
calculating forcing lines it should be
very possible to figure things out
computer computers a bit confused but
this is so much more difficult to play
as White's there's so many things to
worry about
so anyway that's some inspiration to
play the dragon the game didn't go down
this route I missed some opportunity in
this position but I still had like some
nice dragon plans there's a long fight
eventually things work out okay so maybe
I'll post that on YouTube maybe all I'll
make a youtube clip of that of just the
Dragon game with analysis cuz I don't
think I've had any YouTube content just
on the dragon so for the YouTube
audience
thanks for watching let me know like if
you want to see specific opening
contents there's openings that you play
that you want to see the twitch chat can
let me know too but but yeah
smash the subscribe button and I'll see
you in the future alright twitch
audience I'll play one more game
at least I'm 182 I have a street let's
do one more I end up playing the dragon
any chance of Marazzi bind oh so if I
play against a dragon you can only do
Marazzi bind against accelerated dragon
we do have a Sicilian um what am i
teaching against Sicilian I'm gonna play
Knight f3 I'm gonna play some sidelines
yeah like the simple opening Elise
furred for students is to usually either
play the rustle emo or play like the
Bishop e5 check line and then just
complete development and then decide
what to do later but we might actually
be getting like some theoretical game
here I mean this has been a hot topic
opening lately with the World
Championship match and I'll admit I know
very little about any specific theory I
just have like a general idea like where
the pieces should go I'm playing rook e1
because in some cases the bishop goes
back other cases I just take I'm just
trying to be flexible
there's one idea I remember I'm trying
to imagine if it can potentially work
out like this is a probably the prime
opportunity to take to now the lab
Bishop d7 but I'm gonna play h3 which
prevents Bishop g4 it does a la Bishop
d7 which means that I'm going to
preserve the bishop and there's an
interesting idea here I don't know if
it's actually the same move order or if
something has changed within the move
order and okay of course it depends what
lock plays next blacks play me six so I
was actually hoping for a six but this
will be a different game maybe after the
game I'll show what I would do against a
six here I would like to play d4 just
have a nice Center let's do it driving
space all the minor pieces are still on
the board I'm gonna get some more tea I
have a box of tea bags here people see
this this is like my kind of tea
turmeric or honey chai turmeric vitality
can't spell that without Eric let's play
play Knight c3
and I'll be back okay
Queen b6 and this looks attractive
I poured hot water I need a bag I have a
threat of doing this I also have a
threat of drinking tea not sure which is
stronger queen d8 giving me two free
Tempe how do I maximize this is not
defended you could attack it and then
Bishop C is but really like Bishop f4 e
five I guess can play d5 right away and
T 5 is interesting cuz d5 of takes takes
the e file opens in my favor if black
doesn't take I take here it's fine for
d5 when your opponent plays slow in the
opening and you're developed you want to
open the center it's like the main plan
and chess wait aren't you supposed to
put the water before you put the bag
that's what I've been told by multiple
people because if you put the bag and
then the water like the hot water can
destroy the bag but I mean that might
not change the fact that I might be a
monster it depends on the tea I need to
do more research
back first huh
I mean the proper ways to make tea is
without a bag I was like the loose leaf
stuff but that's too too advanced for me
can I take your do I take care first and
the child is blowing up on how to make
tea oh man
okay I think I should take care of first
I want to keep she I don't know what I
want to do I want to win this pawn can I
just take it right away probably can
takes takes takes I mean that looks
really good
my King is not weak because black can't
really attack it
Oh hot water can burn coffee
okay copy pot seems very knowledgeable
there's a word that was just mentioned I
don't know if I want to say I don't know
what it means though all T should be
boofed
no idea what that means oh thanks for
the bits jeez Bates
appreciate that and thanks camel clutch
sure for answering questions yeah people
have questions just just get camel
clutch sure to answer I can can probably
endorse most of his answers okay so I
could take care first I could take here
first
why does well take one writes this pawns
weak if takes takes I win another pawn
b2 could fall but that's okay
yeah life is very good
what is your ba Oh
yerba is a type of tea Oh your first
bits you're kind of new to twitch well
congratulations
yeah a lot of people get confused
because there's bits
there's subs like all these new twitch
terms yeah this is a nice opening block
just played a little too slowly now is
getting punished I mean this is a dream
right sit back relax enjoy the position
drink some tea okay
we've traded Queens if King goes here
it's on an open file let's take the pawn
if Rick be it i play this attacking this
Bishop takes rook b1
yeah so I'm up upon positions very nice
my pieces are more active this is still
weak box works are not connected so now
maybe there's some decision do I play
this tacking this but allowing King f7
or do I play this preventing King f7 I
like the like the prophylactic move just
trying to keep this rook stuck and then
preparing the rugby southern Bishop g5
maybe the double up on the seventh here
I can play Bishop I should h6 if King g8
I probably have to move the knight at
night c4 keep some initiative yeah the
pigs on the seventh that's a dream okay
so Bishop g7 so maybe now I can
calculate takes takes rook here probably
king over King f6 I have d5 so probably
Keaney I fates but then here and my
dream will come true yes I was rook here
but then the light still pinned and my
dream will still come true also rook
here there's Knight d6
winning material let's just make sure in
96 48 takes there is King f8 ah and I
can play e5 and if he takes I take
defending the run oh wait no II 5 look
look still hanging what's going on here
here takes Oh King I fail they take on
e6 looking out 6 I play you 5 ok
so everything works out
GG rating keeps going up 2 points yeah
I'll show one quick idea I'm not sure if
this was the exact position but as a
similar idea there's a nice trick here
is after a bishop or after a 6 I was
going to play Bishop c4 which looks kind
of maybe pointless because it encourages
black to play ball 5 but there's a nice
kind of underlying positional idea after
a bishop to f1 so it seems like white
just wastes a tempo moving c4 and then
f1 y can actually use the fact that
black has played b5 to his advantage and
the plan here like let's say Knight f6
the plan is a 4 make very nice
positional move and it's very subtle
like White's not winning material but it
weakens black and in such a way like
black either has to overextend that
maybe the bishop can return or I think
if rook b8 could even consider 93 or
taking in then 93 but something like
this could be nice
so very seldom like positional chess I
think it comes from a different move
order though it comes after d6 castling
by 57 I think in this move order it's
probably more common the at Bishop c4
let's go to masters yeah we can see okay
it's only been played four times oh
maybe it's not so well-known yet I
thought b5 but the computer really likes
us for whites maybe just some slight
edge okay
just another tidbit of opening prep yeah
one more game
wait it's 4:10 already a little bit
tired
um it's taking too long maybe not one
more game I'm kind of tired I want some
sushi it's happy hour like most places
like this is prime time for a happy hour
and by happy hour I mean like discounted
sushi so I think I'm gonna end things
there I'm sorry to tease one more game
I'm finishing clean kind of thanks guys
for watching favorite sushi roll there's
a place in st. Louis they have what's
called the oMG roll and they light it on
fire and then you say you say OMG and
you eat it it's really good